نبقى في عالم كره القدم وخبر ثاني من
الجزء الاخر لكن من العالم فالمعروف في كل
مباريات كره القدم انه الفريقين اللي راح
يلعبوا ضد بعض ويدخلوا من ممر خاص بيخرجوا
في من غرف تبديل الملابس للملعب لكن اللي
صار في مباراه في دوري زامبيا كسر القواعد
وغير الدخول المالوف والمعروف لي اللاعبين
فلاعبي فريق لموانا دخلوا الملعب بطريقه
مختلفه تماما ومو متوقعه من فوق السور
مثل ما شفتوا اللاعبين ما دخلوا من الممر
لا قفزوا من فوق سور الملعب غرابه الخبر
مو بس كيف دخلوا لكن كمان في الاسباب
فالسبب وراء نطه من فوق السور هو انهم
خايفين من السحر فبحسب وسائل الاعلام
ذنبيه لاعبي فريق لاموا انه منافسينهم في
فريق جرين بوفالوس بيستخدموا السحر عشان
يفوزوا عاملين السحر هذا في غرفه الملابس
والممر للملعب فقرروا ينطوا من فوق السور
عشان يتفادوا السحر طبعا وفي كلام منتشر
يعني عن استخدام السحر بين انديه افريقيا
وفي كلام واخبار دائمه عن اللجوء لاعبين
وانديه للسحر والشعوذه لتحقيق اهداف معينه
يعني بشكل لكن اللافت عاد بعد المباراه
كان انه الفريق اللي نط عشان خايف من
السحر وتاثيره على اداءه ورغم النط من فوق
السور لكن برضو خسر المباراه وهنا عاد
المنافس ما فوت الفرصه فوتو قال استمروا
طبعا يسخروا منهم ونشروا على فيسبوك صور
اللاعبين كيف دخلوا الملعب وقالوا
لمتابعينهم في حال فاتكم الخبر اليوم
منافسينا كده دخلوا الملعب